what is up ruth my eldest my daughter is
15
and she is facing a diagnosis of
schizophrenia
okay okay let's stop right there that's
a lot
right yep and by the time my family gets
to this point means you guys have
endured
a hard 15 years is that right
uh probably more like seven or eight or
nine years
um in her case no her symptoms are
pretty new
okay so tell me about anything that has
been life-changing
um and so there's a lot to figure out
and uh
so anyway the the there's a lot to
figure out but the question that i have
for you is that
one of the things that we're wrestling
with the most is that she has expressed
to me more than once that
she would like to share this diagnosis
with her
friends with her teachers okay with our
extended family
and that brings up a lot of fears for
myself and my husband her father okay
and we were wondering
what advice you would give us and you
know if it was your daughter what advice
would you give her about that
part of the decision uh okay first thing
i love your heart
awesome question thank you for being
bold and brave and asking this question
and we live in a world where that that
level of bravery that you just asked
we can't do anymore because one group's
gonna say you're nuts one group's gonna
say you're discriminatory like
i appreciate your heart um so
when you say facing a diagnosis of i in
a relatively out of nowhere um
this thing just showed up what is
showing up
um about four months ago she came me
very upset
in the early morning and told me that
she was having
she was seeing people okay um she's
having visual
hallucinations of people okay every day
and no have they done neurological exam
just no brain lesions or anything
correct um we've pursued a lot of
different
tests to try to rule out all of the
possible physical explanations
um there are a couple outliers that we
are still trying to get approved by the
insurance
um but they are outliers you know we'd
have to get like a full pet scan
yeah she's had all the obvious ones
she's had all the blood work for
parasites and she's had the mri and
she's had you know all of those things
checked
is she having um is she
going to war with these people that
she's seeing is it
an uncomfortable thing or is it just a
recognition that there are people there
that i
know intellectually are not there they
are not threatening
um they are unsettling because she knows
they're not real
okay okay um and so
what has when you say they're facing so
they're schizophrenia obviously for
those who don't know
you often whittle it down it's it's a
process of elimination to
land on a place right exactly um
we're running out of landing gear okay
what
is the benefit of this diagnosis
because this is a relatively permanent
diagnosis
um i'm not entirely sure
um you know she's just completed another
round of
neuropsychological global evaluations
um and we're waiting on those but it
looks like
you know something in the family of
schizophrenia is pretty much our only
option
okay and regardless of the exact name
how is she doing the question is still
the same you know
what does she do with this well here's
here's why i'm getting it here's where
i'm getting at
what actually is happening um
if this is yeah if this is
has to do with like a neurological issue
if this has to do with
um like surfacing traumas if this has to
do with
several things several things that are
not schizophrenia
right that is not confirmed um
that you have this diagnosis then i
would recommend
telling people i'm really struggling i'm
um
having challenges i am seeing thing
those kind of things don't bother me
here's why maybe
okay maybe i rephrase the question okay
maybe like take the label or
schizophrenia off the table
okay how do i answer the question from
her
i want to tell my friends that i see
people who aren't there
gotcha okay do i tell her that's okay
that that's safe
or do i tell her that's a bad idea
so here's the balance i want you to
strike number one
if this is schizophrenia this will be
with her for the rest of her life
and this will be something that she
navigates and negotiates and i don't
want her for a
second going to war with her own body
going to war with her own mind
right i don't want her hiding things i
don't want her trying to put com
parts of her heart and her mind in a
compartment
the more that she can own who she is own
her challenges
the the biggest challenge with someone
with schizophrenia is keeping them on a
treatment plan
and if you can keep people on the
treatment plan keep them taking their
meds and keep them practicing you know
hygiene and connection with their people
then there is some some successful
outcomes right
it's when people start when they stop
being stop stop being a part of their
treatment plans
and that comes from compartmentalization
that comes from hiding that comes from
withdrawal
and suddenly people are out and so part
of me says
good for her the other side of that is
if this isn't confirmed
yeah i don't want my 14 year old just
going to school and using this
as a way to connect with other people
right
absolutely i mean give her teach your
kids something and go well that didn't
turn out how i planned
we were intentional and deliberate and
we taught our kids
that we keep surprises but we don't keep
secrets that's right because
secrets hurt people right and she says
to me i don't i don't want to keep this
a secret
and i don't
i don't know how to meet that and say
what to do with that next
there's a difference where i would where
i would change it is
there's a difference between a secret
and something that's private
and when it comes to medical things when
it comes to
our bodies some things are private
they're not secrets they're private
right so um if
i've got some kind of medical condition
that might be embarrassing right
um i might tell my friends hey i've got
some
medical issues man i'm not gonna be able
to go to this or that i may
i'm not gonna encourage a child to
disclose everything that's going on with
their body
because other kids can't hear that
right now talking to you i agree i i'm
afraid of what
can happen if she opens herself to this
and she's
unmoored and she's scared and you know
everything doesn't seem quite real right
now and i'm afraid of her opening
herself up to being hurt in a new way
right but i don't want to turn this into
something that she has to hide some sort
of
thing that's wrong with her i mean she
she comes to me and she says you know
mom what if we can't figure this out
what if they they can't figure it out
what if i'm just crazy
and one of the most terrifying things
and i've had a few interactions with
kids over the years who are heading down
this road
and it is a it is a trajectory that's
why i thought you had dealt with it for
several years
for it to emerge like this in that way
um
that my first thought is something
physical but again i trust you and
definitely trust um your family and your
doctors so
um the most terrifying part of this
pushing them pretty hard
yeah the most terrifying thing and i'll
tell you
um i'm just being honest with you as i
can okay
the most terrifying part in my
experience is walking alongside young
people in this situation
is that they can consciously feel
themselves losing their mind
they see it they feel it happening and
it's they there's seasons when they know
there are people here or i am having
hallucinations of
or i am feeling that i am being listened
to by that clock over there whatever the
the challenge i've experienced and they
also simultaneously know
there are no microphones in that clock
there are no other people in this room
other than you deloney
and that in and of itself is the
scariest part i can feel myself
unwinding and so i think as her mom your
job is to say
you will never ever be alone in this
deal
as long as i can help it and you will
never
lose us you're never going to lose love
you're never going to
lose this connection here as long as i'm
on this planet i'm plugged into my baby
girl
and what i wouldn't tell her hey that's
never going to happen because that's not
true i would say yeah this is really
scary and scary for all of us
and you are not walking through this
alone and when she says things like
mom what happens if i lose my mind
that's when you respond with
that just sounds so scary doesn't it
tell me about what you're feeling
you can't promise her one thing and you
can't promise for the other thing you
can
walk you can model for her i'm listening
to these fears
right and as a parent i know how
powerless this feels
right for sure powerless
i do think it's important that she not
set herself up with her peers
she said you said she's 14 15 15
15. yeah i would i would draw a
distinction between private and secret
right and maybe
um i'm trying to think of something
i'm trying to think of something that's
not um
i don't know if i had testicular cancer
i would tell my closest closest buddies
i would not announce that
in big spaces not because i'm
embarrassed about testicular cancer but
i don't want to have
extended conversations with people that
i'm not close to about it you know what
i mean right
and so one of those is i would tell
people i got cancer
and they'd say what kind of cancer would
be like yep and
they'd go they know exactly what i meant
because i'm grown up right and there's
people that i would talk to about it but
i wouldn't just go put that out there
because of the impact on other people
not on me
if you listen to this show enough you
know i'll just talk about anything
so i think teaching her the difference
between secret and private is one thing
the second thing is making sure she's
got people at school she can talk to
her so she knows she's not broken she's
not dirty she's not disgusting she's not
gross it is not normal
it is out of the ordinary but she is
still beautiful however she was put
together
and so making sure she's got coaches or
teachers
or guidance counselors at school that
can give her a safe space
and what i'd recommend is having
somebody she can see face to face so if
you went and met with a school counselor
have you all done that um
it's very difficult they just open the
school for people to
that aren't students to come in so i
could physically go see her counselor
now but i haven't yet
i would write an email to the school
counselor exactly what you told me
that we've been getting testing over the
last four months this has emerged and
this is what where we're headed
and we want you to help us with some
guidance with our young one on how to
navigate this at school
i'm not comfortable with a 15 year old
owning this narrative
here's why it may go away and here's why
it may not be schizophrenia
if i'm you i would tell the doctors i
want to the
diagnosis of schizophrenia to be a last
thing we only do that if we have to
unless insurance says we're not paying
for the meds unless unless we have to
um and i want to see if there's some
other ways we can work through this has
she already taken start taking
um antipsychotics or she already taken
medication
um we started with some anti-anxiety
medications
um working on that angle to see if that
was kind of feeding this
um and that didn't really help she's on
the lowest dose of an antipsychotic
right now okay
it has helped but they're not gone okay
all right
is there any sort of behavioral
interventions
diet exercise go outside play with
people
um not different than our lives were
before
um we're fortunate enough to live far
enough outside the city that we've got
property and animals and she's out
and getting that vitamin d and that
activity regularly so
very cool what's her interaction with
other people is she allowed to do that
um
can she play with friends can she play
with kid other kids
um she is involved in in so much
like i said she's she's a rock star um
she's
you know in some clubs and some
organizations um
outside of school that keep her moving
yeah um
and and and keep those connections going
but it it's all everything's a different
format this year
okay yeah and part of me wonders man
is there some sort of environmental
issue here some sort of physical issue
then the combination of those
has set some things off that when she
gets more into a routine and gets back
and again that's me being optimistic
here
so here's a bigger question
how are you and your husband dealing
with this how are you all
um my usual response is to uh
to dig in and give myself lots of
practical things to do so
right now my job is just to tell the
doctors and get as many tests as i can
and have those conversations with her
when she's scared
um i i know that from
from other crises in my life that i will
have to circle back around and
and do some work on myself as well but
i'm i'm not there right now
you didn't answer my question though
how's your marriage
um interesting
um i don't know that i've ever heard my
husband say i'm scared
yeah in as blatant as terms as he has
lately
yeah what was your response to that
me too he's a very practical person he
can learn how to do anything
he can if the plumbing's working he'll
just fix it and if the car needs
something he'll fix that and
if the electrode is not working he'll
fix that in addition to the two jobs
that he's working so
you know he came to me and he's like i
this is the first time i've just looked
at something
gone i have no idea what to do with this
here's what here's what you do you put
down
the solution part of this because y'all
can't solve this
okay what you can do is stay
hyper connected to one another continue
to be vulnerable and proud of you
for um inviting him into that
conversation i'm
proud of him for being a vulnerable guy
living out on acreage saying to his wife
i i don't know what to do feeling scared
is right
and what i'll tell you is i've seen
these things when student students
of mine have been on treatment plans
that they
hang in there and can go about life
are they always going to have challenges
yep they are thinking about life
and then i've seen some hard things
where kids get off their treatment plan
and things are really difficult
and so the fact that that your
daughter's got a
bulldog of a mama in there ready to go
to war on her behalf is wonderful
it's great you've got to temper that
with
putting your own oxygen mask on too
and you've got to temper that with
knowing that part of
her journey is a safe house
and a safe house starts with a you
and your husband intimately tethered
together
rock solid that we're in this for the
long haul
and letting your daughters be heard and
not making any promises that we can't
uphold
and here's the thing this is just scary
and it sucks and it's awful and um
it's that lack of power it's that lack
of control right
yeah i'm sorry
and um i wish i had i wish i had better
options for you better news for you but
all this stuff
um but going back to your original
question to me
is um yeah there's a difference between
privacy and secrets
and some things for 15 year olds need to
stay
private they need to stay a secret and
stay private but she does need to have
some folks at school she can talk to
that when she does get scared when she
does get unnerved
she'll have a signal with the teacher as
a signal with the guidance counselor
she'll permission his get up and go into
the
counselor's office and she'll have a
group of adults watching her while
you're not there and that will give you
some peace of mind in your heart
and hopefully the doctors can get to a
resolution relatively quickly and then
begin
a treatment plan that's going to be
hopefully short-term but more likely
long-term
and the more we can practice the more we
can get her connected with other people
and the more we can get her following
this treatment plan the more it will
become part of her rhythm and her the
rest of her life
um 15 for whatever it's worth is pretty
young
usually it's late 1819 21
up to 25 and so i'm gonna keep my
fingers crossed
this is something unrelated and that
she's struggling with
something else and it's not
schizophrenia and we're gonna
just stay optimistic and keep praying
and
keep hope alive on this one
ruth uh i i just can't thank you enough
for your heart let me know how those
conversations with the school go
and make sure she's got some folks there
and continue to
look at your daughter and let her know
she's beautiful she's perfect the way
she's made
this is scary and while you can't make
the
scary things go away you will be with
her right you will
be with her